وداع أليم وأخير ليس الأول للمراسل
الفلسطيني الموقر،
ابنه الأكبر حمزة، وهو
صحفي زميل في قناة الجاز، قُتل في
غارة جوية إسرائيلية في المنطقة الجنوبية لخ
يونس يوم
الأحد، ووري الثرى
بعد أشهر قليلة من وفاة والدته وشقيقه
وأخته وابن أخيه.  قُتلوا في غارة
جوية على مخيم اللاجئين في غزة،
يبدو من المستحيل التعبير عن يأس هذه العائلة المطلق
بالكلمات، ومع ذلك، يومًا
بعد يوم، من خلال
خسارة الكثير من الأرواح، فإن الكلمات هي التي قدمت
شهادة حاسمة على الواقع الذي يواجهه
الجميع في
غزة يوم
الاثنين عندما قصف الجيش الإسرائيلي  أكدت
أنها نفذت الغارة الجوية
التي قتلت حمزة وزميله
الصحفي في قناة الجاز مصطفى الجاز، قائلين إنهما
استشهدا بضرب إرهابي،
ورفضا تقديم مزيد من التفاصيل،
وتقول إسرائيل بشكل قاطع إنها
لا تستهدف الصحفيين، وتصر على أن
الجيش الإسرائيلي يستهدف حماس.
ردًا على هجوم 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول،
لكن من الصعب التوفيق بين
النوايا المعلنة لإسرائيل والعدد
الهائل من المدنيين الذين قتلوا
في الغارات الجوية التي شنها جيشها في
جباليا، وكانت الجثث متشابكة تحت
أنقاض هذا المبنى السكني، حيث
قُتل ما لا يقل عن 70 شخصًا هنا، كما
يقول الناجون.  في الليلة التي كان فيها الكثيرون
نائمين، كان هناك شعور بالحزن في جميع
أنحاء غزة في المنطقة الوسطى من دار البلح، حيث لم
يتبق سوى القليل من الأمل حيث يقوم الرجال بالحفر
بأيديهم العارية في بحث يائس
عن
ناجين في مستشفى AA القريب،
وهو مركز رعاية الطوارئ الوحيد الذي بقي
يعمل.  في المنطقة، أصبحت الفرق الطبية
مرهقة بشكل خطير الآن، وقد أجبرت التحذيرات الجديدة من
الجيش الإسرائيلي الأطباء
من العديد من الدول الدولية على
إجلاء مرضاهم
ولم يتبق لهم أي مكان آخر لتحويل ما أراه
اليوم داخل المستشفى هو
عار مطلق على الإنسانية.  رأيت
أطفالاً مضرجين بدمائهم
رأيت طفلاً أصيب بشظايا
ولا يعرف متى يكون عائلته
رأيت امرأة أصيبت في وجهها
بضربة وانتظرت ستة أيام ستة أيام
كاملة  لقد
كان القتال الدائر حولها شرسًا للغاية،
لذا فإن ما رأيته داخل هذا المستشفى يجب أن
ينتهي، حيث لا تزال الدعوات لوقف
إطلاق النار تذهب أدراج الرياح، ويزداد
الوضع الإنساني في غزة يأسًا،
إنه أمر صعب للغاية.  واقع
وثقه صحفيو غزة بشق الأنفس مرة أخرى
على الهواء بعد ساعات قليلة من
دفن ابنه حمزة، وهو رمز للصمود
بالنسبة
للكثيرين ولكنه أيضًا رمز
لتصميم العالم على رؤية
والاعتراف بالضبط بما يحدث
داخل غزة ندى بشير سي إن إن في بيروت